so you write infrastructure code in  terraform how does terraform monitor  your applied configuration stay tuned to  learn more this is where the terraform  state becomes relevant the state is a  metadata file of your infrastructure  configuration stored by default in a  local file it can also be stored  remotely which is often preferred in a  team environment  any change you make to your  infrastructure true terraform is  reflected in the state file  terraform uses the local state to create  plans and change your infrastructure  before any operation terraform does a  refresh to update the states with the  real infrastructure  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  the description box to enroll in the  getting started with terraform for  Google Cloud course see you there